Kevin McCarthy is officially out as the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
Mr McCarthy is the first speaker in
history to be ousted from the job by a
vote and he is out
because Republican Congressman Matt
Gates led a rebellion of just eight
Republicans to vote against the speaker
since the GOP majority in the house is
so thin eight Republicans was all it
took to defect and along with the
unified votes of the Democrats who
didn't want to vote to save McCarthy
they all brought McCarthy's brief tenure
to a close here is Congressman Gates
defending the uprising
look at that big ass look at that big
juicy booty sorry that was an audio clip
of AOC over a picture of ilhan Omar
licking her lips literally licking her
lips while staring at the backside of
Congressman Gates yesterday I'm not sure
how that video got in there here is Matt
Gates defending the uprising Kevin
McCarthy is the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and he has failed to
take a stand where it matters so if he
won't I will I make no apologies for
defending the right of every
hard-working American to afford a decent
life for themselves and their families
and we have a greater opportunity to do
that and to build coalitions under new
leadership we have to rip off the
Band-Aid we have to get back on a better
course and Mr Speaker I don't know how
this vote's going to go usually when a
vote comes to this floor it's pretty
predetermined and this one I'm not so
sure but I am sure that we've made the
right argument
that this place deserves single subject
spending bills that we should have 72
hours to read a bill that's something
that spends more than a hundred million
dollars shouldn't be put on the
suspension agenda such that we can't
amend it and there shouldn't be Secret
side deals made on a continuing
resolution to lump Ukraine in with
border security that is a that is not
right for Ukraine or border security
because it fails to give either of those
issues the dignity that they would
require let's get our act together let's
get on with it let's vacate the chair
and let's get a better speaker I yield
back all fair points all fair the only
thing that wasn't totally fair about
that was the Tailoring on Matt Gates's
jacket he needs a better tailor but
otherwise he sounded great he looked
great he raised a lot of totally legit
points
but now the question that we are left
with is
what now
what happens now
McCarthy wasn't great
but he was far from the worst in fact
this is probably damning with faint
praise but it's still true Kevin
McCarthy is probably the most
conservative speaker that Republicans
have had since Joe Martin in the 1950s
he was certainly better than Paul Ryan
certainly better than John Boehner
arguably he was more conservative even
than Newt Gingrich
but he lost the trust of some key
conservatives so now he's out
and now there is a vacancy for the worst
job in all of American politics I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
there are some studies out that suggest
that antidepressants are linked with
stunted sexuality and that birth control
pills are linked with divorce we'll get
to that in just a moment first though I
don't want to move off of the speaker
issue too quickly and I know a lot of
people are asking Michael who should be
the next speaker is is Kevin McCarthy
going to run again no he said he's not
going to run again he could have just
run again maybe whittled away at those
eight Republicans giving them more
concessions and then but he says no I
don't want the job some people are
suggesting well it could be Matt Gates
Matt Gates is never going to get those
votes it may be Jim Jordan that would be
amazing I love Jim Jordan he'd be a
terrific speaker but I like him too much
to wish such a terrible job on him
there's no no way I you know he hasn't
really expressed his desire for the job
in fact the one prominent person who has
put forward his name to be the next
Speaker of the House
is Matt Walsh and so I would like to
officially and fully endorse Matt Walsh
for speaker Matt has a lot of experience
in Washington I know that he's been busy
dancing but I think that he could bring
to bear all of that work
that he has done for the vice president
and others in Washington uh to the
speaker's chair to that gavel so Matt
Walsh has my full ringing endorsement
and the top reason
why I am endorsing Matt Walsh or really
anyone over over myself because you know
you don't need to be a member of
Congress to be speaker in theory uh the
reason is because
under no circumstances
would I ever seek the speakership of the
House of Representatives because it is
the single worst job in Washington DC
one would probably rather clean out the
portable latrines on the National Mall
than be the speaker of the house it is
absolutely terrible it is hurting cats
at best and you'll be thrown out and
called a bum and called the worst person
in the world you get absolutely no glory
you get absolutely no thanks and the
recent Republican speakers have ended
their careers in shame
so no
no who would want that job why is it so
bad it's not the worst job if you're a
Democrat
people love Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi
was able to accomplish a lot of things
not very good things but she was able to
accomplish a lot she has a lot of
influence she has a lot of prominence in
the Democrat Party she's helped shape
the Democrat agenda
she's still lauded as one of the leaders
of the party the same cannot be said if
Paul Ryan the same cannot be said of
John Boehner even Newt he was the most
effective one we've had in a long time
uh perhaps other than Kevin McCarthy
well the Newt Gingrich was certainly
more effective than Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy might have been a little bit
more conservative but regardless why is
it that the Democrats do better in the
job than the Republicans do the reason
is because for the Republicans it is an
impossible job because the Republican
party is split in in Far More distinct
ways than the Democrats are the
Democratic party is split between
extremely Progressive people and
slightly less Progressive people
there aren't really very many
conservative Democrats at all maybe
Henry Cuellar of Texas would be but he's
probably the only one okay so you've got
the extreme far left liberals you've got
AOC and ilhan Omar and and then you've
got the slightly less extreme ones like
Nancy Pelosi but they're all on the same
page directionally they're all facing
the same way and so it's easy to Wrangle
them with the Republicans
you've got the conservatives mostly in
the freedom caucus and then you've got
the liberals who are the moderates who
are the ones who agree with Democrats on
a lot of issues but they're at least
nominally Republican and they vote with
the Republicans on some issues and we we
want them to be with the Republicans so
that we don't get completely blown out
in these votes but how do you reconcile
those things when it comes down to
foundational premises of politics all of
the Democrats are on the same page when
it comes down to foundational premises
of Politics the Republicans are split
you got the conservatives
and the Liberals
and
that the two will never get all that
close together so anyone who's going to
Wrangle them is going to have to be able
to be a little bit squishy which is
going to irritate the conservatives and
the conservatives rightly are going to
say well I don't want to go along with
that if if the choice we have in
Congress is between super duper liberals
and slightly less intense liberals then
what's the point that's not a choice
that's an echo
and so they're going to pull their
support
the
ousting of Kevin McCarthy
should not come as a surprise to anyone
it's been occurring in slow motion
but it should not come as a surprise to
anyone
this was baked in the moment that Kevin
McCarthy gave in to some of the demands
of the conservatives which is he offered
them the motion to vacate the fact that
they could just with one member stand up
there and say no more speaker he offered
them
all sorts of concessions on committees
he offered them which is one of the
arguments as to why he wasn't wasn't the
worst speaker we've ever had he offered
them
a lot more prominence and he made them
promises that he was not able to keep
and so they asked him who takes over now
few names have been floated Beyond Matt
Walsh which is Steve scalise House
Majority Leader and Tom emmer House
Majority Whip
and Donald Trump we'll get to which of
those it should be in one second first
though
what are you looking at online do you
think I'm not talking not that I'm not
you shouldn't be look not like bad stuff
you shouldn't be looking at bad stuff
but what are you reading conservative
websites are you reading things that are
perhaps a little subversive to our
liberal regime you probably don't want
the powers to be very vindictive powers
to see that that's why you got to check
out expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com Knowles have you ever
heard of data Brokers they are the
middlemen collecting and selling the
digital footprints that you leave online
they can stitch together detailed
profiles of your browsing history online
searches and location data and sell it
off to advertising companies who use the
information to serve you targeted
advertisements no biggie right well
you might be surprised to learn that
these same data Brokers are also selling
your information to the Department of
Homeland Security and the IRS to mask my
digital Footprints I am so pleased that
I can protect myself with expressvpn one
of the easiest ways for Brokers to
obtain data to tie it back to you is
through your device's unique IP address
which also reveals information about
your location
when you're connected to expressvpn your
IP address is hidden making it more
difficult for data Brokers to identify
who you are expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your network traffic keeping your
data safe from hackers on public Wi-Fi I
have the expressvpn app and look you
know I'm a Luddite okay so you can get
it on your phone you can get it on your
tablet you can get it on your computer
you can get it on your home Wi-Fi router
and it's simple enough that even I can
use it you tap one button turn it on
boom you're protected that easy make
sure that your online activity and data
are protected with the best VPN money
you can buy visit
expressvpn.comwles use my link to get
three extra months for free
expresvpn.com expressvpn.com Knowles
who's going to be speaker
probably not going to be Steve scalise
Steve scalise would be a great choice
for it but he is suffering from a pretty
brutal cancer diagnosis
so it's probably not going to be him
Elise stefanik the Republican from New
York who's a little bit lib but she has
played her cards pretty well and she's
been on the right side of trump uh she
is the House GOP conference chairman
however she is being talked about as a
potential VP pick for Trump so she
probably doesn't want the speakership
Tom emmer is the House Majority Whip uh
he is kind of on the wrong side of trump
and whether you love Trump or hate Trump
Trump's a big figure in the Republican
party not a great place to be
uh when he was nrcc chairman that's the
Congressional Campaign Committee for the
Republicans he encouraged Republicans
not to mention Trump's name on The
Campaign Trail
he was pretty critical of trump in 2016.
he I don't I don't know I don't really
maybe emmer gets it he's probably the
most likely candidate right now or he's
definitely in the top three uh
McCarthy says he won't run again Thomas
Massey
uh is I can't imagine he's extremely
conservative and he was opposed to the
motion to vacate for the same reasons
that I said because he said McCarthy I'm
not saying McCarthy is great but he was
the best we've had in a long time and I
don't know that we're going to do much
better so who could it be could it be
Trump himself
I think it should be Trump
assuming Matt wants to focus on his
dancing career I think the speaker
should be Donald Trump
because that is the funniest of all
options and because there aren't any
notably better options before us the the
best option probably would be Jim Jordan
Jim Jordan has said repeatedly he has no
desire to have the job he would much
rather stay where he is on the Judiciary
Committee he's doing excellent work
there on the Judiciary Committee I like
him personally I really like Jim Jordan
I don't wish such a terrible job on him
and Trump would have a lot of fun with
it
and it would it would just because we're
we're in this moment
of political upheaval where the
Democrats have destroyed basically all
of the Norms of our political order and
they're focusing all of that destruction
on the person of Donald Trump
then the way to to bring all of this to
the fore would of course be to put Trump
in the number three position in the
entire U.S government
and then just you just kind of wait to
see what happens
if for instance well here's a great
reason why it should be it should be
Trump
Donald Trump right now has has been
threatened with a gag order
so the judge in one of the zillion
Trials of Donald Trump the judge in this
financial trial where they're trying to
take away his companies and they're
trying to pretend that his companies
aren't worth very much money even though
we know that they are they're pretending
that mar-a-lago's worth 18 million
dollars Mar-A-Lago does 25 million
dollars a year just the business forget
about the property the property is worth
hundreds of millions of dollars but
they're trying to take this away and
they they issued a gag order on Trump
judge Arthur and Goron issued this
limited gag order
against everyone in the civil case to
stop verbal and social media posted
swipes at members of the staff because
Trump took a swipe at one of the judge's
staff members and pointed out that she's
a huge live Allison Greenfield is a big
lib she's a big Democrat and Trump said
this is a crooked case and I'm just
being politically persecuted and look at
all these big Libs on your staff and the
judge says you can't talk about how
we're all big Libs or if if you do talk
about it we're gonna put you in jail for
30 days so here's my proposal Donald
Trump becomes Speaker of the House of
Representatives
he then
as the leader of the lower body of one
of the branches of government he has
opened debate on the floor of the house
and he gets to say whatever he wants and
the judge can't do a damn thing about it
because that would lead to a
constitutional crisis more of a
constitutional crisis than we're already
in
he's probably not going to be speaker
but it would be really funny could you
imagine could you imagine sitting there
at the State of the Union
all right ladies and gentlemen here's
the president okay
um I'm the president not that jerk okay
uh speaking of
speaking out
and and even assuming that Donald Trump
by the way is not the Speaker of the
House Trump should violate this gag
order
he certainly should violate the gag
order I I'm not sure that I would have
said A week ago that he should call the
members of this judge of Staff big Libs
but now he must
he has to do it because
all of these prosecutions are a
ridiculous farce none of them have
anything to do with any crimes that
Donald Trump supposedly committed
he's not being brought up on rape
charges give me a break in New York he's
not being brought up on Insurrection and
call the evil horrible crime of calling
the secretary of state of Georgia when
you're president of the United States or
this that I don't even remember all the
charges now of of overvaluing his
businesses give me a break
he's not being brought up on any of that
because they are crimes he's being
brought up on those things because the
liberal ruling class wants to destroy
the former president and current leader
of the political opposition
that's all it's about it's all just
about 2024.
and so Trump has to speak out let them
put him in jail let them there are still
some people probably not you if you're
listening to this show
I don't care if you love Trump if you
hate Trump if you're a left-wing
Democrat
if you are listening to this show and
you pay attention to politics you know
that this is a political persecution
but there are some people
very unfortunate people who perhaps
don't yet listen to this show who
naively think
that these trials are really just about
the blind law being uh evenly
distributed to everybody and Lady
Justice where's the blindfold and so
Donald Trump he's just going to be held
to account if you did anything wrong
some people naively still believe that
let them put him in an orange jumpsuit
let him sit in a jail
let the reality of this political
persecution set in of what a Banana
Republic the Democrats have made this
country into
let that set in I think it would help
Trump's campaign
I think it would even if it hurt Trump's
campaign I think it would be good for
the American political order
because we would have to confront a very
nasty reality which is that we are no
longer governed like a bill up on
Capitol Hill and all the other BS you
learned in your civics class if we were
governed that way we are governed that
way no longer and we're not going to fix
the problem until we acknowledge it
speaking of speaking out
speaking of people with power
Pope Francis
has signaled an openness to a sort of
same-sex blessing not gay marriage
exactly but kind of a same-sex blessing
and potentially even a type of women
woman Priestess
sort of maybe situation in the Catholic
Church
this is all extremely complex one
because the libs lie as journalists
but I'm I don't want to blame everything
on the live journalists here two because
the Holy Father tends to speak in a way
that there might to be a little bit
ambiguous
three because the Jesuits and Pope
Francis is a Jesuit the first Jesuit
Pope ever uh they have a habit of being
a little cagey not the way that they
speak
uh four because the Catholic Church
being 2 000 years old and at least in my
view divinely instituted has a lot of
layers to it you know there's there's
mystery there and and so it can't be
easily uh you know jotted down in five
bullet points on the back of a napkin
but
that is why even though I usually when
Pope Francis is in the news I say oh who
cares I'm not I'm not concerned about
that things will sort itself out uh but
it's it's not uh it's probably being
misrepresented but here this is really
worrisome because the Catholic church is
headed for something called a synod
unsynodality what is that your guess is
as good as mine it is a meeting of
Bishops and lay people and non-catholics
for some reason who are all joining
together it's not an ecumenical council
it's not people don't really know what
it is
and it's
potentially a campaign
to restructure the the very constitution
of the church
and there there is the possibility that
the church which has uniquely held firm
against these errors of modernity that
have infected other institutions things
like the contraceptive mentality things
like abortion things like the sexual
Revolution you know especially we've
seen those three things in the last 60
years the Catholic church has held firm
even supposedly liberal popes like Pope
Paul VI held firm issues Humanity which
which says no contraception no abortion
no none of that weird stuff
Pope Francis has said you cannot bless
sin Pope Francis has said things that
that seem pretty
Orthodox pretty Catholic
but then we see in a response to
questions that were supposed to him by
his Cardinals
uh
he seemed a little ambiguous about
whether priests can
issue blessings
of say of same-sex situations let's call
it situationships maybe end of women's
roles in the church so my takeaway
perhaps we'll get to this Anthology
Thursday because
this is a big deal in the Catholic
Church being the Bedrock institution of
Western Civilization even if you're not
Catholic you probably would would agree
with that statement uh if there are
big disruptions afoot in the Catholic
church that is going to affect everybody
whether you're Catholic yet or not
ultimately I'm not concerned because I I
believe that the church is divinely
instituted and I believe that our Lord
will never leave his church and I
believe he sent the holy spirit to guide
the church but this we could be heading
for a very very scandalous moment so
we've got to we've got to peer into that
I think it was Pope Paul VI who said the
smoke of Satan has entered the Vatican
that there was this period of of intense
upheaval and danger that we were
entering into
when things enter your home how do they
enter sometimes by the windows that's
why you got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text nulls to 200 300
for most homeowners window replacement
is not something that they've done
before for many it's not something that
they want to do but something that
they've got to do have you put off
replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive then I've got
great news you can now get a free
in-home window consultation and a free
quote from Renewal by Anderson I heard
totally unsolicited from a carpenter who
just listened to me do a read for
Renewal by Anderson he wrote and he said
Mike I just want to let you know of all
the homes that I go and see and work on
the ones that have Windows from Renewal
by Anderson they've got the best work
for sure and coincidentally I have a
cousin who works for Renewal by Anderson
he's been telling me about them for
years years before they ever came on
this show so I've heard a lot of great
stuff about them and you're going to see
that great stuff when you hire them
Renewal by Anderson is offering a free
in-home or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for zero dollars down zero
payments and zero interest for one year
text no to 200 300 for your free
consultation save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings won't last long so be sure
to check it out text Knowles to 200 300
that is Knowles 200 300 texting privacy
policy and terms of conditions posted at
textplan.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text message
marketing and message and data rates may
apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details when Dr Jordan B Peterson made
the decision to join daily wire plus it
was a major win for those who Champion
intellectual debate with one year of
unparalleled to Output his contributions
have set new standards and remain
unmatched by any other platform daily
wire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan content offering
hundreds of hours of captivating content
you won't find anywhere else Jordan has
created thought-provoking works that
reshape your perspective on life such as
vision and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men Additionally you can
immerse yourself in discussions that
nurture your spiritual side such as
logos and literacy and Jordan's
groundbreaking Series in the book of
Exodus that is only the beginning there
is also his Beyond order lecture series
and an extensive Archive of lectures and
podcasts this is the absolute compendium
of all things Jordan plus is even more
new exclusive content on the Horizon by
becoming a daily wire plus member you
will embark on an unforgettable
experience that will fuel your thirst
for knowledge and Inspire personal
growth like never before go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member today
speaking of weird sex stuff
I was having this conversation the other
night with sweet little Elisa and we
were just talking about how the world
has gotten so crazy and why men and
women are acting so weird about each
other and Elisa raised the question she
said you know Mac
it's kind of like a little bit weird how
we just pump women full of hormones and
chemicals for like decades at a time you
know starting when they're like 13 years
old and Mac do you think any of the
relationship problems the divorces
whatever could that be linked to that I
said you know girl that's that's an
interesting
suggestion as are many of Elisa's
suggestions so then I Googled it and it
turns out she's probably right I found
this uh story which originated in the UK
independent
uh so you know major paper that suggests
that marital problems are a side effect
of birth control use
85 percent of people in Britain said
that their marriage or relationship had
been impacted by contraceptions side
effects
according to this survey here women who
had ever taken hormonal oral
contraceptives the pill that sort of
thing divorced at a rate
above the study average
women with tubal ligations who had their
tubes tied divorced at a rate 78 above
average
uh husbands who have had vasectomies
uh were twice as likely to divorce the
divorce rate for couples who had ever
used condoms was 67 above the average
and
on the flip side of things women who
actively used natural Family Planning
which is uh something that the church
has encouraged in the past and it's a
little more uh a little more natural
and one hopes it is to be used so that
you can have more children not used as a
as a sneaky backdoor into contraception
uh but it's it's one that Christians are
a little more inclined toward
we're 47 percent less likely to divorce
than the average
if you considered women who had ever
used NFP ever in their whole lives the
group was still 31 less likely to
divorce now you could say
well right the reason for these numbers
is that if you ever use contraception
then you're Pro you're not going to be
Catholic you're not going to be
practicing the Catholic faith for
instance and Catholics say that you
can't get divorced and modern Libs say
that you can get divorced so that's why
they're more likely to divorce
same goes for other religious
communities
it's Michael it's that their behavior
vis-a-vis contraception is indicative of
deeper beliefs and the deeper beliefs
are responsible for their behaviors
relative to divorce okay yeah maybe
maybe yeah sure but that explains a lot
of it
could it also be though we we know that
contraception we know that the pill for
instance
changes women's biochemistry and it
could have effects on the kind of men
that they're attracted to and how
they're attracted to them and different
mood swings and all the rest of it is it
possible
that by radically altering women's
hormones and biochemistry for decades at
a time we're kind of messing up the way
that they relate to the men in their
lives it seems likely to me at the very
least we know that other drugs are
messing up kid people's sexual
development especially kids sexual
development antidepressant drugs which
everybody is on now a shocking number of
Americans are on these depression pills
that radically alter the brain chemistry
uh we we now have a story just came out
yesterday that antidepressants could
stunt teenagers developing sexuality uh
as they grow older really depressing
that teenagers are on antidepressants if
teenagers are on antidepressant
something is going seriously wrong in
the culture from the family all the way
up to the political order
into the medical order that we would
just prescribe kids these very powerful
drugs why are these teens so depressed
rarely do people discuss how this might
affect their development but it turns
out we know that antidepressants Tamp
down sex drive in adults and uh it would
appear that it has similar odd effects
on the sexuality of kids could the
widespread prescription of
antidepressants have something to do
with the
[Music]
strong
now speaking of liberal activism really
sad story that went viral yesterday as a
guy a 32 year old activist
who was stabbed to death by some vagrant
wacko at 4am in Bed Stuy and he was
leaving a wedding with his looks like
his girlfriend and uh young white guy
apparently a real do-gooder you know uh
liberal social activist
um and he's there with his girlfriend
and there's a vagrant in Bedford
Stuyvesant I mentioned he's a young
white guy because bedstuy is a black
neighborhood it's overwhelmingly a black
neighborhood so this guy stands out
bedstuy is a poor neighborhood this
guy's wearing a suit his girlfriend is
wearing a gown and this vagrant walks by
and for some reason
this young man this 32 year old man gets
up with his girlfriend and follows the
crazy vagrant and starts speaking to him
when this vagrant it looks like he's
beating up on a car or trash can or
something and the guy showed courage in
that when when the vagrant pulled a
knife out and starts attacking him he
put himself in between the the attacker
and his girlfriend
and then he was stabbed to death it's
down on the ground and this was all
captured on camera because cameras now
are everywhere
the the sad I mean the sad part about
this is this young man died uh
some people are kind of mocking it and
saying well he got what he deserved you
know play stupid games play stupid
prizes I'm not doing that that's you
know this is a very sad thing if a guy
gets murdered especially if he if he is
trying to help his girlfriend but what's
really
what is especially sad and what's
politically important for all of us is
the shocking way that he and so many
people today
misjudge these sorts of situations which
we'll get to in one second first though
McMuffin 19 gave my famous comment
yesterday and he said Libs always say
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
but will pull a fire alarm to stop a
vote that's true you can't yell fire in
a credit theater unless the Republicans
are passing a continuing resolution that
you don't like then then the Supreme
Court has said you are allowed to pull
the fire alarm especially if you can't
read and don't know
don't know what fire alarms look like
uh
bedstuy is a very bad neighborhood
wasn't a biggie who raped about bedstein
Do or Die My bedstuy is not a nice place
I just looked up the crime statistics in
Bed Stuy your chance of becoming a
victim of crime in Bedford Stuyvesant is
about 1 in 35.
the violent crime rate is 1065 per 100
000 people the average crime rate is 2
900 per 100 000 people
it was four o'clock in the morning
this is a a young white couple dressed
to the nines from a wedding
they're going to stick out like a sore
thumb
uh some people have said well it's crazy
to be in New York City at four o'clock
in the morning it's not crazy to be in
New York I've been in New York City at
four o'clock in the morning many many
times all over the streets in all sorts
of parts of New York
but if I'm gonna be out on the street at
four o'clock in the morning it's when
the bars get out in New York I'm gonna
be in nice neighborhoods I'm not going
to do that in bad neighborhoods and
there's a difference between bad
neighborhoods and nice neighborhoods
and you're not allowed to say that now
because it's Politically Incorrect
to suggest that certain neighborhoods
are more prone to Crime than others but
they are
and if I see a crazy looking vagrant on
the street I'm gonna cross to the other
side of the street
and I'm not going to talk to that guy
I'm not even going to make eye contact
with that guy
because
some people are more dangerous than
others
you're not allowed to say that now
especially if the person is black even
if the person's white but especially if
the person's black you're not allowed to
say that because that would be called I
don't know they call you racist or
profiling or whatever but
these are these are all natural
reactions
that are conducive to our own safety
the the word that has been totally
trodden underfoot in recent decades is
Prejudice Prejudice is a terrible you're
not supposed to prejudge anything but of
course you have to prejudge things you
have to just act on gut and Instinct you
you don't have time to write a 50-page
thesis on every single question you're
presented with you wouldn't get out of
bed in the morning you would you
wouldn't be able to determine okay I'm
gonna get out of bed and then eat a bowl
of Cheerios and then go take a shower
and then go get my car and drive to work
you'd have to examine every single one
of those decisions every time you meet
somebody
you you wouldn't you wouldn't be able to
know do I shake their hand do I punch
him in the face do I run away
Prejudice I'm not saying you know
cruelty I'm not saying uh you know
unjust discrimination I'm not saying any
of that but but just prejudging just
going going on your gut going with the
wisdom of the ages that is not only not
a bad thing that's a very very good
thing that is essential to our personal
safety and to politics Edmund Burke one
of the great uh anglo-irish philosophers
of conservatism
elevated prejudice
as a very important aspect of politics
because otherwise we're we're going to
be like the utopian liberals we're going
to be like the progressives who say the
past was always bad we got to throw out
they had no wisdom whatsoever and we're
just going to reinvent the world every
single day out of our own stock of
reason but our stock of reason is
relatively limited and when we do that
when we ignore the wisdom of the ages we
actually put even more constraints on
our stock of wisdom on our stock of
reason and we imperil ourselves
and our political Community very sad we
should pray for that guy and we should
pray uh for his girlfriend you know and
maybe even for that maniac
criminal there who I hope is arrested I
hope all the other criminals in New York
are arrested there's another sad aspect
of the story if New York were just
operating like it did during giuliani's
day then the prosecutors would arrest
the criminals and and the likelihood of
being victimized and even in these bad
neighborhoods would diminish greatly but
because of political correctness because
of liberalism because of a
misunderstanding of human nature and
politics
we don't get that and so it's no
surprise when people in in recent days
oddly enough especially
open liberal activists are are
victimized that that should come as no
surprise because
they're they're basing their behavior on
on flawed premises
it's not just bedstuy Henry queller I
mentioned Henry queller at the top of
the show he's a Democrat from Texas but
he's relatively more conservative uh uh
Congressman queller was just
uh carjacked in Washington DC
I was coming in from the capitol uh I
parked in front of my uh my apartment
complex and when I was getting up three
guys came up with uh with guns uh I
quickly analyzed in situations I got a
black belt karate so you got to learn
what to do uh I looked to the left
somebody had a gun to the white somebody
had a gun I had a third guy behind me uh
and uh you got to stay calm so I went
ahead and gave him the uh the car keys
and they took off uh within a couple
hours they were able to recover my phone
my my car uh everything got returned I
want to thank the Capitol Police and the
Metro Police for doing their job
so it's good that there was a relatively
happy ending here and Congressman
Cuellar wasn't hurt and he got his stuff
back
this is a sitting member of Congress
getting carjacked you know the city has
spun out of control when that happens
years ago during the early days of the
verdict podcast
we were we were filming at me and
Senator Cruz and some of the staff were
filming it on somewhere L Street K
Street somewhere in the studio but in a
nice part of DC we're pretty close to
the White House and this was about one
in the morning you know Senator Cruz
would come over after the impeachment
vote and we'd do the podcast they just
park on the street whatever after one of
the early shows
Senator Cruz walks back into the studio
we were cleaning up a little bit and he
said guys someone broke into my car
it was a smash and grab someone just
smashed open a window grabbed stole
stuff out of the car
this is a sitting U.S senator
it's a sitting U.S congressman here
quellar
how do you stop it
it's not complicated
if Rudy Giuliani could do it in New York
City in the early 90s
anyone could do it it's it might not be
easy but it is simple you have to
acknowledge that
the way to fight crime is to lock up the
criminals you have to recognize that the
bad neighborhoods are where the crime is
likely to happen you got to send more
cops to those bad neighborhoods and you
got to harass more criminals and you
gotta lock them up for longer periods of
time when crime is on the rise that
means you have an under incarceration
problem what are our liberal rulers tell
us that we have an over incarceration
well over incarceration talk to me about
over incarceration when the crime rate
starts dropping again
it's it's just a a refusal to accept
human nature and reality as it is well
of course we live in a Time
when you're not even allowed to say that
is it any wonder that we're ignoring
reality on other fronts too the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
Canada wies at check out for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
good